de questions ensuite sur
l'adaptation à cette réalité
dans un contexte urbain. On se
tourne vers Richard Bergeron.
Bonsoir.
- Bonsoir.
- On parle en tant qu'urbaniste.
Puisque votre expertise va nous
aider à y voir plus clair.
On peut toujours mieux faire.
Jusqu'à quel point en ce moment
nos villes sont bien adaptées
pour nos aînés?
- Elles ne le sont pas encore
partout. Mais depuis le tournant
des années 2020, on fait les
choses quand même assez
extraordinaires. Compenser la
manière de réaménager nos rues
pour assurer le confort, la
sécurité et l'ensemble des trois
ça fait beauté. C'est plus
agréable. On le fait très bien
sur la rue Saint-Paul et Sainte-
Catherine dans l'opération du
quartier des spectacles. On crée
de nouveaux parquets. On a
doublé la carte du square
Victoria. Toute sécuritaire. Il
y a malheureusement un
rattrapage à faire.
On est sur la bonne voie. Je
suis optimiste.
- Voilà pour votre optimisme.
Poursuivons sur cette voie de
l'amélioration. On voit aussi
beaucoup de personnes âgées
impliquées dans des accidents.
Qu'est-ce qu'on doit faire en ce
qui a trait au trottoir, à la
mobilité de ces personnes?
- D'abord la sécurité et ensuite
le confort et en troisième lieu,
la verdure. Le total, en milieu
urbain à la fois agréable,
sécuritaire et vert. Cela veut
dire élargir les trottoirs,
profiter pour mettre les arbres
parce que ça fait beau. Tout ce
qu'on fait, les montréalais sont
habitués maintenant. Dans tout
le quartier, ce genre
d'opération qu'on fait. Je
préciserai qu'on ne le fait pas
que pour les personnes âgées.
Ces procédés pour sécuriser les
périmètres scolaires, ce sont
les mêmes que pour les personnes
âgées. Quand par des personnes à
mobilité réduite, sans comme les
mêmes types d'aménagement. Quand
tu as répondu à ces trois
groupes, les personnes âgées,
les enfants et les personnes à
mobilité réduite, tu as répondu
aux attentes de tout le monde.
Et je répète : on les fait très
bien depuis plusieurs années.
Malheureusement, la ville est
grande. Il y a des quartiers
nombreux il y a beaucoup de
travail à faire. On n'en a pour
15 ou 20 ans avant que ce soit
devenu satisfaisant ou à peu
près satisfaisant partout.
- On est sur la bonne voie mais
il faut accélérer un peu la
cadence. Si on parle de cet
effort soutenu au cours des
dernières années de retirer de
l'espace automobile au profit
des piétons et des vélos, quel
genre d'impact cela entraîne
pour nos concitoyens plus âgés?
- Pour eux ça ne les affecte pas
tellement. Vous connaissez le
succès des résidences privées
pour personnes âgées. Les
personnes âgées vont vivre
nombre d'entre eux dans ce genre
de milieu. Par bonheur, il y a
une épicerie au rez-de-chaussée.
Les personnages n'ont pas
l'impression de vivre dans un
ghetto dans ce type de cas. Elle
côtoie quotidiennement le reste
de la population.
C'est en train de se faire. Vous
auriez marié poser des questions
au sujet avant 2005 et j'aurais
été très découragé. Je l'étais à
l'époque. Depuis, on a appris à
faire. Réduire la circulation
automobile, les personnes âgées
n'ont pas de déplacement aux
mêmes heures de congestion.
Cela ne les affecte beaucoup
moins que les travailleurs ou
les étudiants adultes. La
réduction de la capacité
automobile n'a pas d'impact ni
sur les enfants, ni sur les
personnes âgées, ni sur les
majorités des personnes à
mobilité réduite. C'est tout
bon. Au total, cette tout bon
pour l'ensemble de la
population.
- Et les rues piétonnes vont
dans ce sens.
- La nouvelle rue Saint-Paul est
magnifique la rue Sainte-
Catherine, c'était dommage que
ça a pris autant de temps pour
la transformer. Attendez de voir
la nouvelle rue Mcgill collège.
Ça va être absolument
magnifique. Mais c'est seulement
dans cinq ans.
- Il faut bien que ces gens-là
se déplacent d'un endroit à
l'autre. Parlons du transport en
commun, qui est aussi un élément
clé en ce qui a trait à cette
tranche de la population?
- Je vous ferai remarquer qu'il
y a 20 ans, et n'avait pas
d'autobus à plancher bas. Tous
les autobus sont maintenant à
plancher bas. Beaucoup plus
facile d'accès. Par ailleurs, le
programme d'implantation
d'ascenseur dans l'ensemble des
stations de métro ce n'est pas
encore complété mais c'est en
cours. Je vous le dis, ne
décourageant pas les auditeurs.
On est sur la bonne voie. Il
faut simplement pas lâcher. Il
faut accélérer cette
transformation de la ville en se
disant qu'à chaque fois, ce sera
moins douloureux. La nouvelle
rue Saint-Hubert est
extraordinaire. Pour tout le
monde! Je nous dis bravo d'avoir
pris ce virage. Il faut
continuer dans cette direction.
- En ce qui a trait aux soins
d'habitation, le portrait n'est
pas homogène. Plusieurs options
s'offrent aux personnes âgées.
Parlons des logements sociaux.
Est-ce qu'à ce chapitre, on peut
être aussi optimiste que pour le
reste?
- La logements sociaux, on a vu
dans un article publié dans la
presse la semaine dernière si je
ne me trompe pas que c'est
drôlement difficile à mettre en
oeuvre. On a beau promettre des
milliers, au bout d'un cycle de
quatre ans, en l'occurrence d'un
mandat, il y en a eu
difficilement plus que 1500.
C'est fédéral, c'est provincial,
c'est des analyses très longues
et complexes. Il y a énormément
de gens impliqués. Il pourrait y
avoir de la simplification
appartenance dossier pour que
les projets soient livrés plus
rapidement et en plus grand
nombre. Pour que la livraison
soit à la hauteur des annonces
financières qu'on entend. On
entendait annonce 2 milliards de
dollars et au bout de quatre ans
on s'aperçoit qu'il y a
seulement 1500 logements qui ont
été offerts à la population.
Alors, simplification et plus de
rapidité.
- Très bien. On retient ça. On
retient aussi votre optimi